[Music]
Jesse you are a PhD you're a scientific
American contributor you take this all
very seriously as we all will and you
thoroughly well no but I mean this is
this is something that you you're
dedicating your life to studying at the
moment at the at the moment okay
sexual deviants SM exhibitionism these
are all the things that sort of fall
under your purview is that fair to say I
think that's definitely fair to say yes
okay and your belief is that everyone
has a sexual deviance of some kind is
that fair to say if you look closely
enough some some people maybe have more
deviant sexualities than others I think
he was looking at you Richie yeah so do
you really believe you believe everyone
has something well I think you know it's
interesting to look at cross-cultural
fluctuations and changes in what's
normal and what's deviant over time and
it changes so you know we have our
conceptions of what's normal and what's
deviant but that's not to say that it's
it's right or you know it necessarily is
the way that we think it is you talk
about some of the rarer what paraphilias
paraphilias is the technical term you
love outside of the norm okay
or lust really that's what we're talking
about here okay let's say these are ways
that people can become sexually excited
or released clinics that are not normal
for example there's one Climaco philia
tell us like that yeah yeah this is
these are people that can only obtain an
orgasm by falling down the stairs or
tumbling down the stairs it's out there
it's out there how does that have been
verified what are you talking about so
you're saying that someone's like
feeling like they wanna oh man I really
gotta and then so they gotta find a
staircase and preferably the longer the
stairwell but thanks
yeah it can't be like three steps no no
they when I really enjoy it have people
film this have you seen on I've seen
written case reports of this yes you
know it's not it's not common but
they're out there no I would not think
it's common but I'm just picturing how
that works the guys at the top of the
stairs and then they take him away I
don't understand it's not good to have a
ranch house I think yeah
those people get so bugged out I plan to
run a single-level house not fun
what is ornithol philia I think has
something to do with birds but I don't
know these are people who it's a subtype
of zoo Ophelia and Zuma files are people
who actually prefer to have sex with
animals not animals we are animal course
but yeah they prefer to have sex with
animals really get more aroused by
animals than they do other people and
this is interesting because Alfred
Kinsey when he was writing about these
types of topics in the 1940s thought
that bestiality he's the expression farm
bred adolescent males and up to 50
percent of these farm bred adolescent
males confessed having sex with sheep
and goats and donkeys and pigs and all
than Suntree critters in the barnyard
environment you got all folksy there at
the end sundry critters yes so but we
now know so he thought that they were
just simply using them as surrogates for
human partners they couldn't get people
have sex with so they just simply use
whatever happen to be available
available to them at the time but we now
know that there are people that actually
would prefer to have sex with animals
they're not using them as surrogates but
they're actually more aroused by by
other by other species so that's a
subtype to have sex with a bird it's not
a bird it's in a tree it's flying away
I was gonna stand that what it's not a
pleasant thought to think about a large
you know bird with large talons and so
on you're the one devoting your life to
this these are important questions